Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Je m’appelle Alexandre Coulez.
Je suis coach, comédien
et ancien officier.
Je suis ravi d’être parmi vous.
Quand on m’a demandé d’intervenir
sur le sujet «Bas les masques !»,
j’ai tout de suite pensé
à cette citation de Shakespeare,
extrait de sa comédie
«Comme il vous plaira» :
«Le monde entier est un théâtre
et tous, hommes et femmes,
n’y sont que des acteurs.
Et chacun dans sa vie
a plusieurs rôles à jouer.»
Cette citation de Shakespeare sous-entend
que nous portons tous des masques.
Des masques au théâtre,
ceci depuis la Grèce antique,
mais des masques également sociaux,
au quotidien.
«Bas les masques», ça revient
à se démasquer soi-même,
mais aussi à démasquer les autres.
Et vous, portez-vous des masques ?
En avez-vous conscience ?
Quels sont-ils ?
Quel rôle jouez-vous dans la vie,
ou au travers de vos profils
sur les réseaux sociaux ?
L’important, tout d’abord,
c’est de prendre conscience
de l’existence de ses propres masques.
C’est un long chemin d’introspection
qui demande du travail sur soi.
C’est la réponse au «Connais-toi
toi-même» de Socrate.
Mais aussi pour répondre
à des questions plus globales
que tout être humain
est amené à se poser :
Qui suis-je ?
Suis-je un ou plusieurs ?
Qu’est-ce qui me rapproche des autres
et qu’est-ce qui m’en différencie ?
Et une fois que vous avez pris conscience
de l’existence de vos propres masques,
vous pouvez passer à l’action
et aider donc les autres
à se démasquer, à se dévoiler,
et tomber évidemment vos propres masques.
Donc pour répondre à ce sujet,
«Bas les masques »,
je vais m’appuyer sur
ma propre expérience professionnelle
et me démasquer
à travers mes trois masques :
armée, théâtre et coaching.
J’ai un passé de décideur militaire
puisque j’ai servi pendant 28 années
dans l’armée de terre
et plus logiquement dans le génie
et à la Légion étrangère,
jusqu’au grade de colonel.
J’ai donc alterné des postes
sur le terrain, en métropole,
mais aussi aux quatre coins du monde,
mais aussi avec des postes en centrale,
en état-major parisien,
dans le domaine des ressources humaines,
de l’organisation et des restructurations.
Pourquoi ai-je choisi
de servir à la Légion étrangère ?
C'est une vaste question.
Depuis mon enfance,
je suis attiré par l’ailleurs
et donc le goût de l’aventure
a été l’un des moteurs de ma motivation
pour m’engager à la Légion étrangère.
J’ai énormément voyagé
sur le plan professionnel,
mais aussi sur le plan personnel.
Seul avec mon sac à dos
et sur les cinq continents.
Et j’ai donc passé onze années à la Légion
étrangère dans tous les grades,
comme lieutenant, commandant
une section de 30 hommes,
comme capitaine d’une compagnie
de 150 hommes
et enfin comme colonel commandant
un régiment de mille hommes.
Qu’est-ce que la Légion étrangère ?
Certains, peut-être, la connaissent
de nom ou de réputation.
Mais peu la connaissent
vraiment de l’intérieur.
C’est à la fois une troupe
connue et inconnue.
La question essentielle,
c’est comment des hommes
venant des quatre coins du monde,
ne parlant pas la même langue
et ne partageant pas la même culture,
arrivent à constituer une troupe d’élite ?
Ce sont les secrets que
je vais vous révéler.
Tout d'abord, la langue commune
de travail est le français.
Donc, on leur apprend à peu près
500 mots de vocabulaire
et il faut les entendre parler français
avec leur accent de leur pays d’origine,
c’est toujours très exotique et poétique.
Deuxièmement, ils sont amalgamés
sous commandement français
et enfin, ils partagent
des valeurs communes,
ce que l’on appelle :
«le code d’honneur du légionnaire»,
qui est composé de sept articles.
Je peux vous donner quelques extraits :
«Chaque légionnaire
est ton frère d’armes.
Tu ne l’abandonneras, quelles que soient
sa nationalité, sa race, sa religion.»
Ou un peu plus loin,
«On n’abandonne jamais
ni ses morts ni ses blessés.»
Donc, vous voyez que la Légion étrangère,
c’est vraiment une troupe d’élite.
Et en plus, on ne demande jamais à
un légionnaire, et c’est une tradition,
la raison pour laquelle il s'est
engagé à la Légion étrangère.
Par goût du risque, par goût
de l’aventure, par goût du baroud,
par rupture amoureuse, sociale, politique.
C’est son secret.
Il ne le révélera uniquement que s’il le
veut bien et s’il a confiance en vous.
Donc c’est ça, vraiment,
qui est très, très important.
Et vous, avez-vous quelques secrets ?
Si certains sont trop lourds à porter,
vous pouvez vous engager à la Légion
étrangère de 17 à 40 ans.
J’ai également fait pas mal d’opérations
extérieures sur des théâtres de guerre,
ce qui m’a permis de lever un
certain nombre de voiles sur la guerre.
Tout d’abord, la guerre,
ce n’est pas tout le temps.
Les périodes d'accalmie succèdent
aux périodes de combats.
En plus, ce n'est pas non plus partout.
Généralement, la guerre est limitée
à des régions, villes ou quartiers.
Et ce qui est de plus en plus difficile,
c’est d’arriver à distinguer
les combattants de la population,
dans la mesure où ils vivent
au milieu d’elle.
La guerre, ensuite, est ambivalente,
avec deux faces.
Une face évidemment négative
que tout le monde connaît
puisque les gens s’entre-tuent.
Mais aussi avec une phase
beaucoup plus utile
dans la mesure où elle permet à certains
légionnaires, évidemment, de se dépasser,
de se révéler.
Et donc à la guerre, les masques
tombent tout rapidement
puisque le chef vit 24 heures sur 24
au milieu de sa troupe.
Donc, on ne peut plus se cacher.
Et certains légionnaires,
d’ailleurs, se révèlent,
d’ailleurs pas forcément
ceux qu’on attendait.
C’est ça aussi le mystère de la Légion
étrangère et l’importance de la guerre.
L’armée n’est pas non plus connue pour
être le lieu où l’on montre ses émotions.
C'est même plutôt le contraire.
En tant que chef, on a plutôt tendance à
contrôler et à maîtriser ses émotions.
Ce que l'on appelle le masque du chef.
Pour moi, cela a été renforcé par le fait
que je pratiquais les arts martiaux
et notamment le judo.
Et donc, il a fallu que j’apprenne
à déposer cette armure, ce blindage,
et on ne le fait
évidemment pas facilement,
notamment dans deux grandes occasions,
à savoir quand on partage des moments
de détente avec ses soldats
ou inversement, dans des moments beaucoup
plus sombres, tragiques, graves,
marqués par les morts et les blessés.
Et dans ces cas-là,
il faut accueillir ses émotions,
les accepter et ensuite les partager.
Tomber le masque de l'armure.
L’Armée entretient également des liens
étroits avec le coaching et le management,
mais on parle plus facilement de
commandement que de management.
Donc, management en relation
centré sur le lien,
management de projet
centré sur le contenu,
ou management opérationnel
centré sur la prise de décision.
Moi, au cours de ma carrière,
j’ai expérimenté ces différents styles
de management
en fonction des postes que j’ai occupés.
Management opérationnel en tant que chef.
Management en tant qu’expert,
et ensuite management relationnel,
évidemment, en tant que coach.
Donc, l’important,
c’est d’adapter votre style de management
en fonction du poste que vous occupez.
Je suis également un homme de théâtre,
Je suis passionné par le théâtre
depuis mon enfance.
J’ai commencé comme simple spectateur
et ensuite j’ai voulu devenir acteur.
J’ai étudié pendant une dizaine d’années
à différents ateliers de théâtre
en région parisienne,
mais aussi à Avignon.
Par chance, évidemment, mon régiment était
stationné à côté d’Avignon.
J’ai pu écumer
tous les festivals d’Avignon.
Et il y a quatre ans, en m’appuyant
sur ma pratique théâtrale,
j’ai décidé de créer ma troupe de théâtre
et donc nous jouons un spectacle par an
dans différents théâtres parisiens.
De plus, j’ai obtenu
ma licence professionnelle
d’encadrement d’ateliers à la pratique
théâtrale à la Sorbonne Nouvelle,
qui me permet d’animer
les ateliers de théâtre.
Pourquoi je fais du théâtre ?
Là aussi, c’est pour lâcher prise,
donner encore une plus grande place
à mes émotions,
notamment par l’improvisation,
mais aussi en incarnant des personnages
à multiples facettes.
J’ai retrouvé dans le théâtre
cette décharge d’adrénaline
que j’avais pu connaître
sur les théâtres d’opérations.
Quand on arrive sur scène,
face à un public inconnu,
on ne se sent pas très à l’aise.
On sent le danger.
Et donc, il faut arriver
à métamorphoser tout ça
pour justement arriver à lancer
et donner toutes ses émotions.
Il y a également un truc
très important au théâtre,
c’est l’utilisation des masques.
Les masques, évidemment,
sont utilisés au théâtre
depuis la Grèce antique
jusqu’au 18e siècle,
en passant par la Commedia dell’arte.
Ces masques sont percés au niveau
de la bouche et des yeux
pour permettre évidemment
à la fois de parler et de se déplacer.
Ces masques indiquent plusieurs choses.
Tout d’abord, ça peut être le sexe
du personnage.
N'oubliez pas, pendant que de très
nombreuses années, les personnages,
notamment les femmes, étaient
joués par les hommes.
Ces masques peuvent aussi indiquer
l’importance du personnage
dans l’histoire,
mais aussi ça peut [indiquer]
son caractère, son humeur.
Sachez que dans la Grèce antique,
il y avait quatre types de masques.
Les masques des tragédies
qui inspiraient la terreur,
ceux des comédies
qui accentuaient le ridicule,
ceux des drames satiriques
qui montraient les monstres
et aussi, évidemment,
les masques des danseurs.
Ce port des masques permet
la levée des défenses et des inhibitions,
c’est-à-dire que sous le masque,
l’acteur est invité à se démasquer
dans son entière nudité.
Evidemment, de nos jours,
les masques ne sont plus
tellement utilisés au théâtre,
mais certains rôles et personnages
peuvent servir également de masque.
Pour ma part, j’ai incarné des personnages
qui étaient assez proches de moi
et des personnages aussi qui
étaient très, très différents.
En incarnant
ces personnages de composition,
je me suis aperçu finalement
qu’ils n’étaient pas aussi éloignés de moi
que je ne pouvais le penser.
Donc, le théâtre révèle
des traits méconnus de vous
et met en avant un certain nombre
de choses que vous avez enfouies.
Le théâtre permet la représentation
de ce qu’on appelle les multiples de soi,
c’est-à-dire que dans chaque caractère,
il y a plusieurs structures et facettes.
L’une est dominante
et d’autres sont récessives.
Le théâtre permet de les révéler toutes,
sans exception et en toute sécurité.
Et vous ?
Quel personnage aimez-vous au théâtre ?
Quels rôles aimeriez-vous jouer ?
Y a-t-il des personnages qui vous
semblent très éloignés de vous ?
Eh bien, observez-les et jouez-les.
Je suis également certifié
executive coach HEC.
Et donc, il y a deux ans,
j’ai décidé de créer
mon entreprise
de coaching et de théâtre,
Mes principaux clients sont
des dirigeants, des manageurs
et des particuliers.
Ma spécialité, c’est le coaching
de transition professionnelle,
le développement personnel
et enfin le coaching de performance.
Et mes outils privilégiés sont la
programmation neuro-linguistique
et les techniques théâtrales.
Le coaching entretient des liens
très étroits avec le théâtre.
Tout d'abord, ils ont une
origine antique commune.
D’un côté, Socrate, qui peut être
considéré comme le père du coaching,
avec sa maïeutique,
et de l’autre côté,
Aristote, qui est le père du théâtre.
Ce sont également deux activités
centrées sur l’humain,
avec d’un côté le binôme coach-coaché
et de l’autre,
le binôme acteur-spectateur.
Ce sont également des activités éphémères,
centrées sur l’instant présent,
que l’on appelle l’ici et maintenant.
Ce sont également deux activités qui
laissent une grande place aux émotions,
au lâcher-prise.
Et enfin, ce sont deux activités
qui permettent de se décentrer,
de faire un pas de côté,
qu’on appelle l’art du détour.
Alors, qu’est-ce que le coaching ?
Le coaching peut se définir simplement
comme l’accompagnement d’une personne,
ou d’un groupe de personnes,
pour leur permettre de gagner
en autonomie de réflexion et d’action.
Ça passe par des phases
de prise de conscience
et enfin, par les phases
de passage à l’action.
Moi-même, je me définis généralement
comme le coach du paradoxe,
avec deux pôles : ordre et désordre.
J'aime bien mettre de l'ordre
là où il y a du désordre.
Mais j’aime aussi mettre un peu
de désordre là où il y a trop d’ordre.
Et en tant que coach,
j’accompagne mes clients
à se démasquer,
à découvrir leur vrai visage,
mais également à trouver des aspects
méconnus de leur personnalité.
Certains clients souffrent
de ces masques sociaux qu’on leur impose.
Et vous, comment vous sentez-vous ?
Êtes-vous aligné ?
Êtes-vous épanoui ?
Y a-t-il une différence entre
ce que vous pensez,
ce que vous dites et ce que vous faites ?
Dans la conception du psychisme chez Jung,
il y a vraiment un binôme qui est capital,
c’est le binôme persona-ombre.
La persona, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
C’est le masque que vous portez,
c’est l’image de vous que vous donnez
vers le monde extérieur.
Il est très important que cette persona
reste suffisamment souple
pour ne pas vous couper
de vos réalités intérieures
puisque la nécessité
de bâtir cette persona
entraîne l’automaticité de
la construction d’une ombre.
Qu’est-ce que l’ombre ?
L’ombre, c’est l’ensemble
de vos frustrations,
de vos projections, de vos pulsions.
Cette ombre,
elle est refoulée dans l’inconscient,
par souci d’adaptation sociale.
Le processus d’individuation
consiste à identifier son ombre,
l’apprivoiser et la réintégrer pour
récupérer toute cette énergie psychique
que l’on appelle la puissance de l’ombre,
qui est source de vitalité
et de créativité.
Car, comme le disait Jung :
«Ce n’est pas en regardant la lumière
qu’on devient lumineux,
mais c’est en plongeant
dans son obscurité.»
Je vous ai raconté mon histoire en me
démasquant à travers mes trois facettes :
armée, théâtre, coaching,
pour vous montrer que
tout le monde porte des masques.
Et vous aussi, vous en portez,
et que l’important, c’est d’aller voir
ce qui se cache derrière.
Pourquoi le faire ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on y gagne ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on y perd ?
Ce qu’on y gagne surtout,
c’est un gain d’authenticité,
c’est-à-dire un meilleur alignement
de la tête, du cœur et du corps.
Donc, vous vivez plus proche
de votre vérité
et vous côtoyez donc vraiment
ce que vous êtes vous-même.
Ce qui est important -
Mon dernier mot :
prenez le temps de prendre conscience
de vos masques.
Et une fois que vous vous sentez prêt,
et uniquement à ce moment-là,
démasquez-vous.
Car comme le disait René Char :
«[Impose] ta chance,
serre ton bonheur
et va vers ton risque,
à te regarder,
ils finiront par s’habituer.»